what's up everyone I'm Alan sock young
it's my 26th orbit around the Sun around
our star that has provided civilization
with energy and given us the ability to
flourish here on earth I've had a lot of
reflecting over the last couple of years
especially about Who I am what my place
is here on earth and I care a lot about
the trajectory of civilization I care a
lot about where did we come from who are
we and where are we going and I've been
very grateful and fortunate to have the
hundred plus billion people that have
lived and died before us today build
this beautiful world that we live in not
only did they provide us with ubiquity
and food and water and shelter and
education and health care and energy
these devices that we're currently using
but also the foresight to do things like
set up amazing botanical gardens and
fountains like this inside of city
centers
so we stand on the shoulders of giants
and it's really important to be humble
and admit that and that our short time
here the two and a half billion seconds
two and a half billion heartbeats 25,000
days is all we have we live about 80
years and in that time what can we do to
make the world a better place for the
next generations to come how can we make
sure that civilizational trajectory is
going towards a place that flourishes
for all it makes it so that we can
collectively progress into the solar
system let's get excited about that
let's figure out earth then progress
into the solar system and you're really
excited about that
so I care a lot about that I stand on
the shoulders of giants I'm really
grateful to have all these really strong
multidisciplinary minds and souls around
me and that really helped me gain a more
well-rounded perspective we just came
hot off of a TEDx San Francisco talk
that I just gave yesterday on the art of
powerful questions that was a really fun
experience I'm so grateful to have had
that opportunity the day before the 26th
birthday which is so great and we're
looking forward we have really cool
objectives that were working for of
course spilling sports stadiums with
thousands of curious intellectuals for
full-day multidisciplinary events
fireside chats debates comedy skits
group meditations all of it we're gonna
get there and writing a lot about time
attention or a real estate the human
race simulation theory I'm really
excited to be publishing that with you
guys soon
I really appreciate you tuning in and
you know getting to know me a little bit
more I really appreciate that we have a
lot of cool things coming up in the
pipeline and again just really grateful
for the world that I was born into this
is a beautiful place and let's cherish
it let's have some stewardship for it
and let's move forward collectively
together as best as we can
much love everyone thank you and
remember ask powerful questions get to
your breakthrough